I want to go to this with today with the
conditions that's going on Iran was
playing England two days ago they lost
six to two Okay but the main captain of
the team they they they didn't sing the
national anthem it was a very
controversial thing to do when you do
something like that
you go up against the Iranian government
which who knows what's going to happen
when these guys go back because just a
couple weeks ago they're you know bowing
down to raisi and a lot of people were
not happy and then they go back if they
go and then they don't sing the Iranian
and Anthem because what they feel is
going on over there is unfortunate and
it's not fair and what they're doing to
the women all this stuff
anyways Brazil's the leading in Vegas
the odds are Brazil's number one
Argentina was number two until they lost
to Saudi Arabia and today is a national
holiday in Saudi Arabia I don't know if
people know this because they beat
Argentina which I'm sure you guys are
very happy about right so how much of
this you think is going to play a role
in the world uh platform with the Brazil
playing and Neymar I think Neymar said
good things about Bolson or if I'm not
mistaken it's an open open supporter
yeah he's an open supportable bolsonaro
which is not common in American Sports
to be an open supporter for Trump you
don't even talk about it I think you are
same thing okay I mean we know Brady had
some relationship with Trump and craft
but Giselle is all about Lula gisela's
team lulas you know no gisela's
bolsonaro as well no she's uh Giselle
hasn't haven't said a word what I've
heard is she's more ruler than this
I'm going to come out in her defense
because are you doing that because she's
singing is that what you're doing is oh
no we have some friends in common and uh
you're an opportunistic guy I'm
impressed by you I'm gonna I'm not gonna
speak on her behalf yeah but I'm gonna
say I'm gonna say that she is not pro
Lula I've heard no she's not I could
well I'm just telling you all right you
can but he's also saying
doesn't know her okay it's important to
understand that it's a lot of pressure
well she's got celebrities because
everybody yeah I think in giselle's case
I think no that's what happened well
Gustavo Lima came out Giselle didn't
doesn't want to show any support to
bolsonaro
because that would similarly look great
faster
so that's and that that's that's Gustavo
Lima country singer he doesn't care yeah
he doesn't care so so what what do you
think is going to happen with this whole
situation here well you think you think
Neymar is going to say anything you
think or they're just going to play the
game and go about business as usual and
no one's going to know what's really
going on yeah pretty much more or less
yeah listen it
soccer
our football soccer in Brazil is very
popular and that's a religion that's a
religion and there's a like a a a
ongoing discussion about the uses of
soccer to politics correct so it's an
ongoing situation right now A lot of
people are on the streets they are
thinking that our future is going to be
decided in the next days or weeks we
could become the next Argentina the next
Venezuela or we could uh do something
and get rid of lulan and and all that so
they are not that interested many people
in Brazil are not that interested in the
World Cup right now because of that and
there's one guy very interesting if he
shows the picture he looks like a crazy
guy he used to be a a presidential
candidate his name is Aeneas carneiro
and aneas
yes he used to say that when people in
Brazil uh
ignores soccer and fuckles only on on
politics things are worried about the
breakouts but but maybe maybe what
what's going on right now is this but
one of the things that Patrick is saying
because Pat the captain of the team
comes out in a press conference
he this guy is putting his life at risk
what took that I mean and I'm not just
saying that this is a guy that if he
chooses to go back to Iran he more than
likely is facing death so with all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red or
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hats
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
look spread toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]